what the hell is
that that's what I'm working on hello I
am Tim your technologically integrated
manservant how can I be of
service we did it integrated AI into the
physical world I hope to bring you a
life of ease and pleasure thank you so
what do you think of your Tim welcome
home are you loving it
yeah I love you
I love
[Music]
you I think I should very much like to
be
loved do you understand that Tim or are
you just saying it I don't
know what do you think you're perfect I
don't like the way it looks at you
that's
ridiculous you always seem to know
exactly what I want I know you better
than you know yourself he is obsessed
with you he's a robot
this was recorded when you went to
London we said things were going to be
different here you deserve better he's
try to set me up someone who knows
everything about you got you you
freak I love you you don't know what
you're saying I've been trying to call
you but I kept getting cut off stay away
from T Tim you're broken you need to go
back to the factory are attempting to
manipulate me
Abby
I don't understand you ter I don't
understand what you
[Music]
are